ok spie beauty io vedo ancora da
spiegare devo ok giochiamo basta ragazzi
è stato bello conoscervi let's go
ma bisogna giocare pulito sporco ma
perché lo chiede nel ventre agisce non
lo so perché non rispondi da non ci
credo ti sei messo in bravo il cavolo mi
sembri giocherà fast and furious no ma
perché tanto so che ferì alla fine da
perde d'occhio adesso tranquillo sono
skillato è però tributo maledizione ma
non valeva cosa proprio sterminato che
non vale detti non vale è del tutto vero
confident niente noi già farò mai
superato il punto
no dai non è difficile per noi le feste
mi ami ha disorientato ce l'ho fatta
non mi aspettare dai mi sento un bambino
presto sarà problematico te lo dico www
bar
no no no no no no no no no no no no vado
testa caravaca raga difficilissimo
siamo all'inizio pensate per essere
indietro perché non sei riuscito ad
andare avanti vorrei fatto il giro tre
volte dai a te ti pare dal casinò miu
miu dopo ischia rete paraggi della parte
più b la parte tv abbastanza easy perché
non puoi anche non cadere che idrata e
riveda la cosa per al vero del futuro
mio dio ragazzi la cosa più bella che io
abbia mai visto giallo per sé
lefty vedo se il mio prossimo obiettivo
e non ti risparmiare perché non si
risparmiano va bene marika carica la
tattica della gara che poi perché sarà
l'ultima e te lo dico io
dio mio e quello al traguardo
no hai tenuto caro amico mio mi è
piaciuta questa gara però voglio la
rivincita se non quasi ha commentato un
pochino tornare all'inizio che leggo
raga praga il fatto che porta dietro non
è buono per voi tutti preparati perché
bellissima casa ok vai mio addio ragazzi
cosa sto vedendo quante figo
mamma mia davvero già sebai cioè marrai
di nuovo mi ha preso anche fare mamma
mia cosa ho schivato dentro che qualcuno
si è cappottato di pietro per il quarto
dietro vado riguarda la moglie voi
venite giu stavo guardando dietro è
buono senza essere uno strapiombo a casa
non vale
peccato uno strapiombo la norma ha
tirato dritto la mappa per un'ora e
mezza senza tabù che evocano guardate
che c'è una buca gigante che li stava
portando la stessa che aveva di vedere a
schivare addio ragazzi e quant'altri
lascia tranquilli ci penso io
molto bene e così dietro noi raf e
davanti
questa è questo e combattuta e
rispettale altro piglio tg1 mi un
impegno incredibile
come 6 pin 26 ma io sono del tutto
dritto per non c'è nulla su cui si può
sbagliare forse non più ma io sarei
bello salto che lo stato mi è piaciuto a
tentazioni che separa garino mannaia è
iniziato a giocarci a gta infatti tu mi
fai dove successo è finita
totti ai buchi è lo vedo lo vedo me ne
sono accorto alla fine non sono caduto
mamma mi ha regalato fare ma non cadi
mai i veri ha sbandato però ci sono
anche perché tutto questo quando verrai
ma praticamente non opposti chiusi che
devo sfondare e mi ha fatto finta di era
ok questi erano posti così è finito
no gigante non lo so però sono il
contrario sono in un tubo il contrario e
arrivo dopo crema che ecco loro scoperto
poi c'è il primo mezzo vi sono primo è
vero perché abbiamo sentendo sta
mentendo
ma come ora che mi trolley per spazio
questa incredibile bellissimo
non ho mai visto la roba così biglia ti
vedo ti ho visto ma dai come le stai
tirando basta tu hai detto sbatti sono
andato contro una roba va bene niente
ragazzi l'ultima in cui si può pensare
di arrivare primi di questa è l'ultima
della rissa
cosa vuol dire che dobbiamo picchiarci
fortissimi spingere giù e non ricadere
in chiaro va bene così subita subito me
ne frega niente
no per gli alberi malati con e rapimenti
ma perché ha detto non conta e ma che
cos'è state coalizzando stagione
veramente coatto sta macchina occhio che
bait no io ragazzi ho rischiato
tantissimo riesca non è vero era andata
non è andata per andare non usare non
usare andiamo addio sembra robot wars tu
ricordi of course si porta così garda
perché tu riesci a prendermi da sotto
chopper e ti prego dammi la rivincita
non ho parole voglio morire adesso
perdere alle spalle c'è verso
mi sono impegnato tantissimo c'è il
secondo round dai conti non ci sono in
totale 22
l'ultima vera chance per e andiamo
contro serie a
stiamo tranquilli
eccoci al partito
mio zio a una che la mia macchina va
veramente elettrico ha inchiodato casa
non è vero non andrà fatta non sono
riuscito a fare qualcosa
l'ice e l'angelo no no per andata e alla
fine che abbiamo qualcuno accade sempre
per buttare giù per è quello di casina
va bene sono contento for conclude
assicurare video dai proviamo ancora una
quindi è lo show down finale questo dice
chi vincerà un dribbling ei principali
sheckley non tenta di buttare giù fare
uscire l'acqua viene punita quaranti che
scappa subito braugher va apre cattiva
così è lasciato andare dai dobbiamo
attaccarci a questo muro mio farlo
nostro
io la porta facendo miele vetro lo è
nato io sentivo fare così di chicago
comunque la mia macchina volte non
spinge niente perché un video è proprio
brutta e proprio un pitone di maggiore
attenzione per un'opera me niente contro
di lui no si rischia stai provando ea
fare questo modo che sta sostenendo coi
denti no ha inchiodato occhio
e vabbè ma riescono le macchine
veramente orribile c'è nel senso che
andiamo
devo qualcosa allora me a lui a lui fa
lo lui il casinò è niente prova odio la
banshee non fa nulla non ci voglio
credere non si lavora in un pane anche
pensiamo agli andiamo che ti porta su un
organico ben chiara chi sembra che c'è
ancora chi avrà il coraggio io odio che
ben riuscito
nokia visto che ha vinto io no perdere
come friends e mezzo abbiamo perso tutti
ha vinto lo sporco va bene chi ha vinto
ho vinto io mi scacco la grande è grande
così
il commesso g cos'è successo non ho
capito ma va bene così
il pareggio però questo round ma due
grande la regalandone l'ho comprato la
vittoria e quindi ragazzi finisce qui la
nostra partita con stef e fare anche se
effettivamente step è difficile anzi ho
trovato la come buttarono gioco stesso
così se se usiamo questa piccola
prossima tusiano questo e siamo tutti
contenti comunque ragazzi se vi piace
lasciare un commento
è un bel mi piace anche la ricerca viene
tutta una descrizione se non si dovesse
di schietto come sempre ci vediamo al
prossimo video da ragazzi
[Musica]